I'm a girl but I think of myself as a
boy. Now I have to suffer with this.
What should I do? Can I do hormone
replacement therapy? Please
answer. There's a Muslim girl who's
asked the question that she thinks she's
a
boy and she's asking that can she do
hormone replacement therapy indirectly
asking that can she change her sex from
a girl to a boy. As far as Islam is
concerned, there is no permission for a
human being to change the sex. Sex
changing is haram in Islam. If you're
born as a woman, you remain like a woman
throughout your life. If you're born as
a male, you remain as a male. These
things happen because you do unnatural
things. You do haram things and these
things happen. Like for example, if
you're a girl and you have been told by
your parents or by your relatives, oh,
you're a boy, you're a tomboy and they
make you wear clothes which are not of
the female of the male, you start
wearing jeans, you start wearing short
tops and you have boycott. All these
things have an impact on your behavior
and you start thinking like a boy and
you start behaving like a boy and then
you want to become a boy. All these
things happening because you are
breaking the law of Allah subhana wa
t'ala and it's common many a time people
start teasing you oh you're a tomboy
they tell girls you're a tomboy and then
she's proud of it and she starts
behaving like a boy. So this is not
permitted in Islam. There's no question
of you taking hormones to change your
sex. Changing sex in Islam is
prohibited. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has prohibited that you have to maintain
what Allah you cannot change what Allah
has given you. And I know there are
medical ways of doing it etc. But all
these are not permitted in Islam. And
you as a Muslim girl should see to it
that you read the Quran, you read the
hadith, you do more ibada and pray to
Allah subhanana wa tala to let this evil
thought go away from your mind. See to
it you read the translation of the
Quran. You read the hadith and you see
things that are more Islamic rather than
things which are non Islamic. See to
that you have friends which are more
Islamic that will take you closer to
Quran and Sunnah rather than friends
that take you away from Quran and
Sunnah. Hope that answers the question.